Tobias welcome to the future of Life
Institute podcast I'm glad to have you
on thanks for having me
all right so perhaps you could introduce
yourself to our listeners
cool yeah so my name is Tobias Bauman uh
I'm a researcher and a co-founder at the
center for reducing suffering which is
an organization that is working on
trying to
find out how we can best produce
suffering
taking into account all sentient beings
and the long-term future
I'm also the author of a book avoiding
the worst how to prevent a
catastrophe which is going which is
talking about the the question of worst
case Futures and what we can do now to
prevent them from happening and I think
these are going to be the ideas that
we're gonna
explore in this podcast episode
oh definitely so let's start with the
central idea here which is suffering
risks or asterisks what's the best way
to frame this idea what's the best way
to introduce it
um so very broadly uh asterisks are just
uh worst case Futures that um contain
suffering on an astronomical scale
suffering on a scale that vastly exceeds
everything that has
um existed so far so I mean nowadays of
course all sorts of technicalities about
you know how much suffering does it have
to be to count as an asterisk but maybe
I think that this is actually not not so
important because I think it should be
clear what we're talking about we're
talking about worst case futures with a
very high level of suffering
this is certainly a grim topic and a a
dark topic So What attracted you to to
thinking about suffering risks in the
first place
I mean I would say that my background is
kind of in like in course prioritization
sort of motivated by EA like you're
trying to do do the most good
and I think that preventing those worst
case scenarios is uh
what it means to to do the most good
from my point of view at least
um so that's sort of how I arrived at
the topic perhaps we could give some
examples of what you're talking about so
it's it's easier to understand uh what
what would be some examples of potential
suffering risks did this exactly
actually a quite a tricky question
because um
when you are giving specific examples
there's always a risk that the specific
example sounds quite far-fetched and in
reality most asterisks are probably
unknowns unknown unknowns or and it's
not like necessarily concentrated in
like a single scenario so there's that
caveat to keep in mind but I mean of
course it's still helpful for the
listeners to to hear about something so
one scenario could be a malevolent
dictator like imagine a future Hitler
that establishes a permanent global
Earth spanning totalitarian regime
perhaps even with access to Advanced
Technology you can see how that that is
a worst case outcome that could result
in a lot of suffering you can look at
Black Mirror episodes you know that that
provides some
inspiration and more examples of uh
dystopian futures of all sorts
but actually it doesn't have to be
something speculative or sci-fi is if
you just imagine
that Humanity at some point expands into
space and then we just continue the
forms of suffering that we have right
now for instance our exploitation of
animals and Factory conscious other
houses then that would already qualify
as an asterisk if it happens on a larger
astronomical scale
there's some connection between
human technology and the stakes at which
we are operating
so would it be fair in your view to
summarize human history as an ever
increasing technological capacity and
with that ever increasing Stakes so we
can we can now do more than we could in
1500 and in 1500 they had
whatever human activity was going on was
lower Stakes than today what's the
connection there with suffering risks
yeah I think it is it is true what
you're saying in in Broad terms at least
that the more powerful our technology
the higher the stakes Are For Better or
Worse like you can use this technology
to reduce suffering or to to increase
suffering
so I mean an example would be I've
already mentioned factory farming that
would just not be possible on the scale
at which it is happening if you only
have medieval technology then that's
just not possible
um so that will be one example of the
sort of dynamic uh it is not uh entirely
straightforward because not all
technology raises the strike and I mean
for instance if you have widespread
contraceptives that kind of Might lower
the stakes if it results in the long
term the toe or decline of human
population
um and there's also a lot of technology
that doesn't directly have that much to
do with our suffering there is
and of course it can also be used to
reduce suffering so there are those
cabinets to keep in mind I'm not
I'm generally careful that I'm not
saying that technology is per se
something bad the point is merely that
it it raises the stakes and therefore
increases the risk of those worst hits
perhaps we are most interested in those
technologies that are most asymmetrical
meaning that they are they have the
potential to increase the risks more
than they can increase the benefits for
us what technologies are you most
worried about when you're thinking about
suffering risks so one example is
um artificial sentience uh if it is
possible to run a complex computer
programs that become second or sentient
simulations of the sort I mean this is
explored in the aforementioned Black
Mirror episodes for instance they have
some scenarios that go in this direction
this is sort of an S risky technology
because it makes it much easier to
create a lot of Minds a lot of beings
and because
there might be there will likely be a
lack of moral concern for those beings
they might not have any power or
political representation but those are
those sort of risk factors
that could make asterisks more likely I
mean of course this is I'm not saying
that this will happen or even that it's
likely
yeah it's just this is an example of a
technology that would be risky because
of this Dynamic of having potentially
lots of beings that are easy to create
and
a possible predictable lack of moral
concern for the well-being of those
artificial Minds whatever you call it so
anything involving sentience or
Consciousness is speculative and it's
difficult to reason about we don't have
a good grasp of this concept as in as we
have of say intelligence in your view
How likely is it that artificial
sentience will develop as we are say
training large
um AI models so is is this something
you're worried about coming along with
that with increased intelligence in AI
models or are you do you foresee a
scenario in which we would try to
engineer artificial sentience for there
to be a problem
that's a very interesting question so
yeah I mean I actually like the focus on
whether or not it will be developed
because what a lot of the discussion in
philosophy and so on centers around is
like whether it is possible in principle
I I think that answer to that is likely
yes that it is possible in principle to
have artificial sentience but like the
the key question is like whether or not
future technology will actually evolve
in a way that results in such sentient
entities
I mean it's possible in principle to
build underwater cities and underwater
Metropolis but you know that doesn't
prove that we're going to do it
so the key question is like
how will future AI technology evolve and
I mean I think that's very very
uncertain so I'm sort of neither
confidently predicting
that there will be artificial sentence
nor am I confidently predicting that the
won't be artificial sentience uh
generally I think we have great
uncertainty about what the future will
be like and I think that's probably
going to be a recurring theme in this
podcast but what you were saying is that
like the question is do people
try to create artificial scientists
currently it seems to me that the focus
is just on
using AI to solve problems
and people are neither deliberately
trying to create our official sentience
nor are they deliberately
avoiding it
I mean I don't know what that tells us
about how How likely it is that the
result will be conscious due to the
program so called logical
so the the only the problem is of course
that we only have sort of one one
example to draw from which is biological
animals and humans that uh
are conscious
as far as we know
um and
of course the the evolution of
artificial intelligence is not at all
the same as as biological evolution
where you have animals that like it's
used sort of used by Evolution as a pain
and pleasure are like useful for
Learning and like then you can ask the
question is that analogous in in the
sort of AI that we currently have
like I mean if you have a language model
that just predicts the next word or
something like that it seems quite
different from what happened in Natural
Evolution
the fact that it's different does does
not prove that such systems can't be
sentient
but but it's kind of difficult because
we only have this one example to draw
from and so so how exactly would we know
um we can we can try to extrapolate from
how we are already treating our computer
programs to how we'll we'll treat them
in the future because you said something
interesting which is that you predict or
perhaps you you believe that that we
will predictably not care about
artificial sentience or at least that's
a scenario that you're that you fear uh
would would come about on on the one
hand we treat video game characters uh
very badly uh we
we engage in combat with them but
perhaps we we build we do this because
we believe that they aren't sentient on
the other hand some chat Bots
um we might
we might treat as if they're conscious
even though they aren't uh in my opinion
perhaps they are and so what can we
learn from how we're already treating
AIS
um about how we'll treat them in the
future
yeah that's a good question I think
what the sort of gut feeling that people
have about whether or not a program like
GPT or Delhi or and all that all of that
whether it's a conscious is probably not
a very good indicator of whether it
actually is conscious
so in terms of whether or not people who
care about it it seems that this more
depends on
specific features that aren't actually
about I don't know the system is
sentient like if you
if you put the program into a robot that
looks cute or something like that then
maybe people are more likely to to care
about it or if it sort of sounds
human-like or so then it then it becomes
more likely that people would care
but still overall it sounds like a
situation that that could be risky like
if you look at our track record in terms
of how we treat animals I think it is it
is at least a reasonable to become to be
concerned about how we're going to treat
those artificial Minds
especially since they might be like
basically completely at the mercy of
whoever will run those systems there's
also even if the the average person
cares about them you know you might
still have some minority or Mercedes so
that will try to
use those systems for
Less Pleasant purposes I don't know
perhaps the the scenario you're worried
about is that we will develop a very
smart AI systems that can help us
achieve tasks but that sentience comes
along for the ride when you when we
develop intelligence and so we want care
that these systems are perhaps suffering
during their training or doing their
deployment when we're using them because
it's they are simply so convenient to
use is that the scenario you're you're
worried about
yes I mean the example of uh animal
exploitation is is a case where it's
just kind of
economically useful because people want
to have cheap meat and it's kind of
useful to factory farms and
slaughterhouses so
and the similar thing might be happening
with artificial uh sentience maybe it's
just useful to have your personal AI
worker assistant and people are just not
gonna care much about the
it's about being of that if it is
sentient it is also
quite simply possible that we will be
wrong in our assessment of whether or
not such systems are sentient just like
how they are there were lots of
philosophers or so in the past that were
confident that animals are not scented
so that's also a possible risk that we
might be wrong in our assessment
of course you can be wrong but both ways
you can also mistakenly attribute
sentience to a system
uh
when it isn't set it I think it likely
isn't but yeah
yeah this is perhaps also something we
could be worried about
um if
large companies are developing AI
systems that to us they say they're
engineered to feel conscious to us
perhaps because it's it's a great
product to sell a an artificial friend
or an artificial romantic partner these
AI models these chat Bots will then feel
conscious to us and you can imagine even
building their AIS into robots and we
would at least waste resources and
caring for these beings if they aren't
conscious if we put aside the the
question of how we're treating them what
this tells us about ourselves and
whether you can be a good person if
you're if you're mistreating even an
unconscious robot
the wasting of resources because you
wrongly think something you said it is
maybe not a very great concern from my
point of view but maybe a greater risk
is that if people you know if you cry
wolves too often then people will not
take it seriously when they actually are
the conscious systems uh or sentient
systems because then it will just be
seen as something wacky something like
that uninformed and crazy people
talk about how the systems are conscious
when they clearly aren't and it's just
ludicrous to think that they aren't you
know that sort of attitude might become
widespread in the AI community and that
that would be a very bad thing so I
think it's important to emphasize
uncertainty about this when we're
talking about it there might be
artificial sentience there might not be
and uh of course if as long as we don't
know there's a good case to be made for
some sort of precautionary stance you
know if there's a certain chance that
it's sent in I think we should still
take that seriously yeah
and what is your current take on this
what do you believe setting aside all of
this uncertainty and setting aside that
we don't have enough data to to
determine this what do you believe about
current AI models are they do you think
their sentence they're sentient uh what
do you think about
say AIS in the next 20 or 30 years How
likely do you think it is that that
these models will be sent in uh actually
I would probably say that this is quite
unlikely perhaps very unlikely uh I'm
pretty sure that the
language models that we have right now
that Lambda is probably not sentient now
within the next 20 or 30 years so that's
kind of also a question about how how
rapidly will AI Advance at all um if
it's if it's not too rapid if we just
extrapolate what's happening so far then
I think it's
it's rather unlikely that that these
systems will be sentient and the
foreseeable future
so we're more talking about something
more distant in my opinion but some
people might disagree it's also of
course
philosophical questions here about the
meaning of sentient sentience and
whether that is a binary thing or like
something gradual like some people might
be saying that they're sent into a very
small degree or something like that okay
that's maybe a different
angle uh yeah so it raises very
complicated philosophical and empirical
questions but I'm definitely not saying
that that the current systems are
necessarily like I don't really
worry so much about how my laptop feels
about me recording this podcast yeah me
neither okay so if we return to the to
the main topic which which is this uh
this issue of suffering risks it's it's
not really an objection but it's a
reaction uh that that I have
um and perhaps other people have to this
to this problem which is just to say I
think they're they're simply so much
suffering in the world already if we
think about the
wait your example of animals in factory
farms perhaps we think about wild
animals suffering in nature we could
even broaden it out to talk about alien
civilizations that we hadn't encountered
yet with a lot of suffering that perhaps
even the universe is infinite and
therefore could potentially contain an
infinite amount of suffering I
understand that this might sound
irrational but do you think that there
is simply too much suffering for us to
do something about it are we overwhelmed
by suffering such that we we cannot help
yeah I mean I can definitely understand
that sentiment and sort of have felt
that myself so I sort of get where it's
coming from
I do not think that it's objectively a
very strong argument because the
importance of helping one being sort of
doesn't depend on how many other beings
there are right that if if your actions
can avert the suffering of say a
thousand individuals then
the importance of that is not lessened
by the fact that there is a million a
billion a trillion that you weren't able
to help you know because you still
held a thousand beings and uh reduce
their suffering so
on this objective level like if you're
not emotional about it uh I think this
is this is not really a strong reason to
stop caring about suffering but I sort
of understand how this might affect the
personal motivation of of many people
when they think about this topic and how
important do you think the issue of
personal motivation is perhaps one
problem with with focusing on suffering
risks is that it's it's very Grim to
think about and perhaps it's also it's
depressing to to to work with
um such that it's it might be difficult
to stay motivated over the long term how
how much of an issue do you think this
is I uh I mean I think this can be the
legitimate points but but it's also not
like objectively a strong reason not to
work on estrus but rather what I would
say is that for those people who can who
have the the psychological disposition
to to remain motivated to do something
about it they should still continue to
work on Esters for people who really
just find it too depressing or stressful
and wouldn't be able to remain
productive while they work on this topic
yeah maybe it's better to do to do
something else so what one shouldn't
Force yeah oneself to do something that
feels
like that that is like and also forms
psychological predispositions
but I would also note that reducing
asterisks can mean many things it
doesn't have to mean that you constantly
think about the worst case scenarios you
can also just
for instance asterisks are arguably
reduced if we manage to improve our
political system our political discourse
making container or Esters are reduced
if we if we spread better values so if
you find thinking about it too
depressing you can simply focus on those
those proxies those risk factors for
asterisk and try to address them
without thinking so much like sort of
Outsourcing the the issue of thinking
about the details of it to to people
like me and focus on on those other
things so that's maybe it can be one
thing to go around it what's the
difference do you think motivationally
and perhaps also objectively between
framing this issue in terms of the the
upside or the downside so what what
you're focusing on here is trying to
avoid the worst possible downsides of of
what could happen in the future is it
perhaps more motivating to to think of
developing or helping sustain a large
flourishing civilization spreading in
the universe or is that does that lead
us astray somehow I mean I can see how
this is more motivating to some people
um not so much for me personally I would
just say that people are all
very different so I kind of don't have
like a single solution
to those issues I should note that my
colleague Magnus winding at the center
for reducing suffering is planning to
write a book on it's called
compassionate purpose which is sort of
addressing those questions and trying to
bridge the gap between
rigorous ethics and these issues of
personal motivation and self-development
so he might go into much more depth on
that I I honestly do not feel that I
have a very
a very good solution to those issues of
personal motivation it works out for me
like I I'm able to stay motivated to
reduce to reduce asterisks although I
mean I I'm not gonna lie I also do
sometimes have have doubts or find it
depressing so I certainly get where
those the sentiment is coming from in
general I think it's an interesting
issue this this question of balancing
our ethical theories and how we we
believe we should act uh if we're if
we're thinking in optimal terms with how
we actually act uh in in everyday life
and and all of the other considerations
that
impact how we how we think about ethics
so our personal motivations and and uh
all of these things actually do matter
and and I think should practically
speaking be taken into account I don't
know if you think of it the same way
no that sounds right
um I mean I think what can be
frustrating uh for many people is is not
so much the aspect of it being
depressing and more the app in the
aspect of
that a single person is always going to
have only a marginal
impact on it but this this holds for any
altruistic cause uh I never said it was
going to be easy
so any person trying to reduce uh
suffering in the future will only have a
marginal impact what does this mean
could you tell us about the numbers here
it's just that
I am one person among 8 billion and so
the impact that my actions have on our
future is is going to go is going to be
relatively small but I mean as I was
saying earlier I don't think that is a
good argument to despair because like
the absolute number of beings that we
can help is still actually very large
because there are such large numbers of
animals and and sentient beings now and
in the future so that means that the
absolute number of beings that we can
help is still very large despite the
fact that it's a small fraction of the
total that it kind of
so there's that how do you think about
the distribution of impact per person if
we if we take a person such as George
Washington or Jesus or someone like that
they seem to me to have enormous impact
over the future do you think this is
less likely to happen now because say
more Avenues are explored by by people
it's diff it's more it's it's more
difficult to make a difference or do you
think we could see a a Washington or
Jesus uh now that with the same level of
perhaps even even a bigger impact on the
future yeah that's an interesting
question because I mean you would of
course always only know in retrospect
you know to people alive at least this
time he was probably just one one
religious preacher among many or so like
and it wasn't clear at the time that
this was going to become a dominant
religion so likewise it might just not
be clear at the moment what is going to
become a dominant
idea or way of thinking
it is I think these issues of impact
attribution can be very difficult
because like can you attribute all this
impact to like Jesus or George
Washington and so on or can you like is
it just that people later on
who endorsed those ideas
that that it is them that you know have
sort of helped collect this George
Washington income in conjunction with
like the later people who endorsed his
ideas that so like how do you divide the
impact between those that that's that
race is like very complicated questions
that I don't really have an answer to
yeah all right let's perhaps take a an
objection to to suffering focused ethics
or to thinking about suffering risks
that that is more objective in my
opinion at least this is just the
question of knowing what we should do
say we are we're all aboard uh the
program with trying to prevent future
suffering the next question then is is
having good knowledge about how to act
such that we actually reduce a future
suffering how much of a problem do you
think this is and do you think because
this is a general problem do you think
it's a it's a specific it's a
specifically a problem for trying to
reduce suffering risks I would say it's
probably a problem for for anything that
is about influencing the long-term
future right that that entails both
suffering risks and other forms
the long-term future
I would certainly agree that it is
difficult to influence the long and
future for
several reasons I want one is simply
that it is difficult to know what is
going to happen in the future that it's
difficult to predict that
another reason is that
future decision makers future actors
might undo anything that we do now and
just move in a different direction
unless there is some sort of login
so I certainly agree that it's difficult
to influence the long-term future
however I I mean it is gradual right
it's not all or nothing uh it seems
unlikely to me that there would be
nothing whatsoever that we can do
to reduce asterisk or influence the
long-term future
and of course then you can make an
argument that the number of individuals
that is affected in with an asterisk or
more generally the number of individuals
that live in the future is just so much
larger than the number of of beings in
the present
if it's like a million or a billion
times as large then if you use an
expected value framework that sort of
outweighs the difficulty of knowing what
exactly to do about it I mean I think I
can understand why
to some people
that doesn't feel very satisfactory on a
gut level
but I nevertheless think it is
objectively a good argument
so what we're thinking about here is
that we have such astronomical Stakes
there there could potentially be so much
suffering that we could prevent in the
future that even though we are we are
very uncertain about how to prevent this
suffering the stakes makes up for our
uncertainty in a sense if you if you
apply the the expected value Frameworks
or if you take that calculation
does does that argument make you uneasy
because you could you could also perhaps
take it even further and think about
well what is the probability that
um
that that there could be infinite
happiness or infinite
um suffering and that might then
outweigh completely any anything else
you could think about so is there is
there a risk of becoming obsessed or
fanatical when when we think in in this
framework yeah sort of Pascal's mugging
I mean I definitely think that there is
this risk and and so there's there's a
balance to be struck here in in several
regards like
you should take those more speculative
ideas seriously but also not too
seriously like taking them with a grain
of salt
and not putting too much faith in in a
particular speculative
idea I think there are good Arguments
for focusing on the long-term future but
I wouldn't go so far as to say that we
should disregard the short term entirely
I mean I think there is a lot of very
valuable work that is focused on more
shorter term issues so the people that
are advocating for farm animals now I
mean I think they have a very valuable
and profile pause and to keep doing this
likewise you already mentioned the the
course area of wild animals of animals
living in the nature in nature which I
mean they actually constitute the the
vast majority of sentient beings on
Earth right now
and so doing something to help them is
is also a very worthwhile class I mean
they're people doing important research
on that at animal ethics at the white
Animal Institute and so you know shout
out to them
so in an effort to try to avoid becoming
fanatical or obsessed with with
um small probabilities of very large
quantities of of happiness or suffering
uh we spread out uh what our activities
such that we are we're doing something
now and we're thinking about the future
also and what I'm hearing you advocate
for is simply that thinking about
suffering risks the risks of of
suffering in the future is relatively
underweight in our portfolio of actions
uh compared to to how we should weigh it
is is that the right way to to frame
this yeah that seems right
um I mean like it just makes sense for
me personally for instance to to focus
on specialize in this because there are
already lots of people that that work on
those other courses so I've picked a
thinking about asterisks as as what I am
working on
so what you're alluding to is that
asterisks are quite neglected which is
something I agree with and then of
course the interesting question is what
are the reasons for that
uh and some of them you already
mentioned it can't just be stressful to
to think about these scenarios it's
easier to look away it's it's not a
pleasant topic for small talk and dinner
conversations it has been my experience
at least
and so there are there are cognitive
biases that can cause us to to
mistakenly dismiss asterisks which is
wishful thinking about uh how the future
is going to be uh great anyway or
I mean there's a concept of denial of uh
ongoing
suffering ongoing atrocities and that
that sort of also applies to potential
future atrocities it's just more
pleasant to look away to Flinch away and
not you know bother with it basically
perhaps on paragraph a little bit so
when you when you say wishful thinking
and denial how does that work uh how do
how do we how does that cognitive bias
influence our willingness to take
suffering risks seriously
yeah so it's a wishful thinking it's
just the tendency to endorse hypotheses
that we wish to be true rather than that
are objectively true and of course we
would all wish for asterisks to be
extremely unlikely or speculative we
would all wish for the future to
go well by default anyway right
so that is
a fact that it can bias people towards
dismissing asterisk although of course I
I also want to be careful here because
there might also Simply Be legitimate
reasons
and like
it it might be a bit arrogant to just
say like okay everyone else is biased
basically well so I mean maybe I'm wrong
you know maybe the other legitimate
reasons why people why Esters have not
gotten that much attention although they
have enough attention given to it I
think is increasing and there is
interest in it so maybe maybe it's true
that these scenarios are very unlikely
maybe it's true that that you can't do
anything about it I I you strike me as a
humble humble person I I don't think
that you that you're just explaining
away uh disagreements with accusing
others of of bias we will go through I I
wrote down a list of potentially
Justified reasons to object here but
before we do that uh perhaps explain how
scope neglect the bias of scope neglect
could influence our unwillingness to
take uh suffering risks seriously yeah
that is another major bias that that can
lead people to dismiss asterisks uh we
just don't really feel the numbers on an
intuitive level right I mean the
suffering like of a single individual
can feel more emotionally
uh moving or touching then the the
potential hypothetical future suffering
of of a trillion or something like that
which is we don't tend to feel
emotionally about that in fact there's
also something called the proportion
bias it feels more satisfying to help 10
out of 10. than to help 11 out of a
thousand but it's I mean objectively of
course it is better to help 11 right so
that that's why I would
call this
a bias and then you you also mention at
some point a belief digitization which
we could also call uh called black and
white thinking and this perhaps uh is
just if we believe that say uh suffering
risks
are very unlikely
um say that there's a one percent risk
that that one of these uh suffering
events will occur in the future then we
round down to zero and then we say well
then it's just completely uh unlikely
that impossible that it could happen
and you could see how that could
influence our willingness to take it
seriously and do do you think you have a
disposition to to be more objective uh
in in the way you you handle
probabilities or is it is it perhaps uh
that you have some some that you're
educated in a certain way to to
understand the small probabilities
yeah I mean I definitely think that it
is very important in general to think in
terms of nuances and avoid like a black
and white and all or nothing thinking of
any sort simply because there is so much
uncertainty about all of those questions
I mean I don't know if there's anything
about me personally that does that uh so
I want to be careful about that but
um and of course I mean just just to be
fair there might also be biases going
the other direction I mean I don't know
something might you might say that you
know it's just sexy to think about those
uh sci-fi scenarios and that's just more
intellectually exciting than getting
your hands dirty and doing something in
the real world but that's why we're
doing it I don't know that could be a
potential counter bias so
but on balance I think
I do think that wishful thinking and the
tendency to look away from from these
dark thoughts
it's a quite strong potential Point what
do you think is is strongest here is it
our our tendency to look away to deny uh
suffering or or our unwillingness to
engage with small probabilities of uh
very bad events what's most active here
I would probably say that the former has
it's probably about what I would give
more weight I mean there is this
question of like whether or not people
are generally biased about small
probabilities I'm not entirely sure if I
buy that there are some I mean sometimes
people also talk too much about
things some sort of catastrophes that
are very unlikely so I mean I think I
could see this going both ways I'm not
sure if people are generally biased
about small probabilities or or if so in
in what way exactly that seems
complicated to me whereas the point that
people tend to look away from suffering
from atrocities from from
dark things unpleasant things that seems
like a fairly clear and strong bias to
me how do you view the issue of us say
taking actions that
unwill where we unwillingly increase
future suffering uh one one thing I I
was thinking about was this issue of
artificial sentience that we touched
upon earlier
um imagine that we in an effort to try
to prevent This research artificial
sentience but by researching it we
understand it better and we make it more
if we we make it easier to create
artificial sensions so that might be a
case in which we we are against our will
um create increasing the risks of future
suffering just because there's so much
uncertainty in this area that we're
trying to engage with might we do harm
when we're trying to do good
yeah that's a great question
um because there is definitely a risk
that our actions can backpack in in many
different ways and therefore we should
definitely be careful
um one should avoids doing research that
makes it easier to create artificial
minds or at least as long as we do not
have enough moral progress to ensure
that they're treated well like that's
that to you know come first before you
create them ideally another conceivable
risk is that one might inadvertently
Empower malicious actors and and they
are PR risks perhaps I think that the
most important risk to be aware of is is
the risk of a backlash against
certain ideas I think there are certain
ideas that we've discussed that might
sound
crazy to to many people if it's not
communicated in a careful way
so and we don't want those things to
become
part of a polarized political debate the
culture War I think that would be a very
bad development if that were to happen
so that perhaps the largest backfire
risk there to keep in mind so it's
important to to be careful about how to
communicate those ideas and to emphasize
um positive song cooperation and
personal Integrity coming back to this
idea of great uncertainty in general I
just think that it is a strong reason
why we need to reflect carefully about
our our views our priorities and why we
should do for our research before
jumping to any premature actions
yeah you we could imagine various
examples of say if you were concerned
about trying to prevent future suffering
in the past say in the 13th century what
might you have graphed on grasp onto
there where if you were prematurely
certain about what you were trying to do
you could have done a lot of harm
perhaps you know perhaps we're in the
same situation now so is it would it be
true to say that one of the main ways to
engage with trying to prevent suffering
risks is to gain knowledge is to do
research because we're at an early stage
in our knowledge
uh yes I think that's definitely true
the way I would put it is that what's
most important now is uh to put Futures
Esters producers suffering reduces in a
better position to reduce asterisks sort
of you could call it capacity building
like one aspect of that is simply to get
more people interested in the ideas to
build the community but another aspect
is what you could call wisdom building
to to increase our knowledge of of those
issues
and and that will put future people in a
better position to to reduce asterisks
it is precisely for that reason that I I
don't really share the the sort of
defeatism that we can't do anything
about it now because what you can do
about it now is to research it and to
put future people in a better position
to do something about it
and
in terms of people in the past it is
also worth noting that
sometimes they did things that were very
impactful like enlightenment
philosophers writing about democracy and
the rule of law and early Animal
Advocates and so on so it's not true
that nobody in the past was able to to
have a positive and arguably like a
predictably robustly positive
impact
on on the future so that's maybe one
argument to push back on on this idea
that we we can't do anything
in addition it's worth encoding that
reducing short-term suffering also isn't
always that easy when you take into
account the fact that the vast majority
of sentient beings on Earth are animals
living in nature perhaps
marine animals perhaps small animals
like invertebrates perhaps insects if
insects are sentient
and so then it's not so easy to know
what what to do about that either
so you're thinking that even when we're
trying to reduce suffering in the short
term
are actions the consequences of our
actions will extend into the future so
such that perhaps it's it's difficult to
avoid uh thinking about the actions long
into the future our actions long into
the future when we're when we're
thinking about what to do yeah I mean
that seems right to me I don't think
it's a very convincing approach to say
that we just only look at the short-term
suffering because as you said in
everything we do probably does have
Ripple effects on on the longer term the
problem is more that it's not always
easy to predict what those Ripple
effects are so you could say that on
average it it it's sort of 50 50 and
washes out like I mean I think there's
something to that but again it's it's
it's hard to argue that this is entirely
true for everything that you do again
like the people in the past that were
for instance promoting human rights or
or the rule of law or something like
that I mean was it really 50 50 whether
or not that is good or bad
um it seems to me that they they could
have reasonably
but
and did think that it is good to spread
those ideas and they were right about
that right so I think it's it's uh wrong
to argue that just everything is sort of
50 50. that seems to be taking it too
far
when we're thinking about reducing our
uncertainty about reducing future
suffering we should perhaps take into
account that
or at least I think that the the fields
of human knowledge where there are
direct feedback loops or short feedback
loops are the fields of human knowledge
where where humans have advanced the
most and perhaps when we're thinking
about influencing the long future we
can't get feedback because the results
of our actions are say a hundred or a
thousand years into the future and so
the feedback loops are very long is it
perhaps a better approach to try to
tackle problems that are more uh
directly in front of us in time so more
short-term issues than trying to learn
from that and then be in a better
position to influence the long-term
future that is that's an interesting
argument and I definitely agree that
this lack of feedback loops that it's a
major
problem in this endeavor to reduce
asterisks or to have an impact on the
long-term future in general so like I
mean this is also something that like
applies to all of long-termism basically
not not just as just reduction
I'm I'm less less convinced that uh
doing some work to to reduce short-term
suffering is necessarily a good solution
to that so that might have some feedback
loops but the question is like whether
whether or not those are the relevant uh
feedback loops
I mean even there the question is like
well yeah what sort of feedback are you
getting exactly so I mean if you're
you can advocate for better animals
welfare laws for instance so I mean
maybe you're getting feedback about
whether or not
you're actually gonna be able to make
progress to getting like a certain
specific law enacted okay you can get
feedback on that but I mean is that much
feedback about like how does that help
us to reduce suffering in the longer
term future so is that it's not
necessarily a very clear feedback signal
for that question of how we best
reduce suffering in the long term right
so that's that's maybe a problem of this
sort of approach makes sense so for the
listeners who are interested in learning
more about the these topics where should
they go which websites or books or
papers should they read
oh gee I mean there's uh lots of
impossible
things
um so I would of course recommend the
website of the of the center for
reducing suffering they're the dissenter
on long-term risk uh also is interested
in asterisk production
but with a slightly different and bent
more focused on on AI on Cooperative AI
maybe we're going to talk about that too
later on
uh there is
I mean Brian a classic would of course
be brought into Messick's uh website on
reducing suffering I would recommend
Magnus windings uh block but of course
of course one shouldn't you know just
read stuff from people that that you
agree with that that's not a good
practice you know so one should probably
read a broader set of offers uh all over
in it on all sorts of topics
definitely great Tobias thank you for
coming on the podcast it's been very
interesting thanks for having me